hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es mal wieder einen
käsekuchen ich habe wirklich schon lange
keinen käsekuchen backen und zwar ist
der dieser mit himbeeren und mit einem
brösel boden also ich habe unten keine
nötig sondern einen brösel teig muss man
also vorher keinen teig zubereiten und
ich habe hier einen kernigen frischkäse
verwendet uns weiß sohn hüttenkäse der
den käsekuchen einfach so richtig toll
cremig macht man braucht es nicht viele
zutaten dazu und die zubereitungszeit
ist auf gering und deswegen liegen es
direkt los
zuerst einmal muss ich jetzt den brösel
boden herstellen und kann aber dann auch
direkt im anschluss die creme herstellen
für den bröseln boden brauche ich 120
gramm löffelbiskuits 60 gramm butter und
50 gramm mandeln das netz geschäfte der
mandeln und für die creme brauche ich
300 gramm hüttenkäse 250 gramm quark mit
20 fettanteil eine bio zitrone 40 gramm
puderzucker etwas vanille extrakt 50 g
speisestärke 300 gramm weiße schokolade
und dann brauche ich noch 200 gramm
tiefgekühlte himbeeren und etwa zwei
esslöffel zucker also zuerst einmal
nämlich jetzt die löffel biscuit und die
butter die butter kommt jetzt in einen
kleinen topf und die lasse ich jetzt da
ein bisschen schmerzen und kann in der
zwischenzeit schon mal die kekse
zerkleinern und zwar mache ich das jetzt
in einem mixer aber ihr könnt ihr zum
beispiel auch einen gefrierbeutel
stecken und mit einem aus holzstab
einfach draufhauen
jetzt kann ich die keks brösel mit der
butter vermischen
und jetzt fühle ich diese brüssel
mischung in eine vorbereitete form und
martin buck habe mit 20 zentimetern
durchmesser mit backpapier eingeschlagen
und kann es diesen brösel boden gut drin
verteilen und drückt es jetzt gut fest
jetzt stehe ich da noch die mandeln
obendrauf und die sorgen so ein bisschen
für den kranken der torte so ein
bisschen las ich übrig stellt erstmals
zur seite und kann jetzt die füllung
vorbereiten
jetzt muss ich die schokolade grob
raspeln
die schokolade stelle ich jetzt erst mal
kurz zur seite und eben die himbeeren
die hälfte davon habe ich jetzt bereits
weg gelegt und die andere hälfte kommt
jetzt in einen kleinen topf gemeinsam
mit den zwei esslöffeln zucker und das
muss ich jetzt auf mittlerer stufe
bisschen erwärmen
bis dahin werden geschmolzen sind und
dann kann ich sie mit dem laufen nämlich
so ein bisschen zu drücken
das kann jetzt hier an der seite einfach
ein bisschen vor sich hin köcheln und
ich kann in der zwischenzeit schon mal
die creme vorbereiten und gibt dafür die
eier gemeinsam mit dem futter zucker in
form aber kommt noch von electric dazu
und dann verliere ich das ganz kurz so
etwa 12 minuten
jetzt gebe ich auch direkt den königen
frischkäse mit dazu und wenn da jetzt
nicht ein bisschen salz mit drinnen
könnt ihr an dieser stelle auch noch
eine prise salz zufügen
das hat eben übrigens da quark jetzt
kommt der könige frischkäse dazu dann
noch die bio zitrone und davon jetzt nur
die gelbe schale also nicht das weiße
das ist nämlich immer bisschen twitter
kommen noch die speisestärke mit rein
und dann werden die zutaten kurz berührt
und zum schluss gebe ich jetzt noch die
weiße schokolade mit dazu und dann ist
die füllung fertig die hälfte der
frischkäse creme gebe ich jetzt direkt
mit auf diesen brösel teig dann gut
verteilen
und da kommen jetzt direkt die himbeeren
mit drauf die ich eben zurückgelegt habe
dann bedenklich die himbeer mit der
restlichen creme
und ich bin aus dem topf die werde ich
jetzt einfach durch ein sieb streichen
denn da möchte ich jetzt die kerne nicht
mit drin haben
und dieses team bike kommt jetzt noch
ganz oben drauf einfach hin zu klecksen
und die kann man jetzt mit einem schaf
sticks oder mit einem zahnstocher bisher
den vorm ziel
den ofen habe ich bereits auf 190 grad
ober und diese vorgeheizt und tabak ich
den kuchen jetzt für etwa 50 bis 60
minuten der kugel ist abgekühlt und ich
habe ihn nach dem abkühlen sogar noch
für eine stunde in den kühlschrank
gestellt da lässt es sich nämlich besser
schneiden so und da der moral ist gerade
nicht da muss ich gleich probieren
der fährt nämlich grad noch draußen mit
mir ein bisschen fahrrad
falls ihr übrigens den kuchen etwas
größer machen wollt also größer als 20
cm
dann findet ihr auf meinem blog eine
umrechnung tabelle und könnt den kuchen
zum beispiel auch in der 26er form
backen und es die ganzen zutaten dann
dementsprechend umrechnen
also da unten haben wir jetzt die brösel
bodenschicht dann diese cremige
käsemasse mit der weiße schokolade und
mit den hüttenkäse und mit den
fruchtigen in bern
und hier sieht man noch mal ganz genau
also der kuchen schmeckt wirklich sehr
fruchtig vor allem hat mir unten diese
brösel bodenschicht und das sind ja noch
die mandel später drauf und wenn man
darauf weist dann knackt es richtig im
mund dann die weiße schokolade in dieser
käsemasse die komplett richtig gut weil
die käsemasse an sich nicht sehr süß ist
aber die weiße schokolade gleich das
ganze dann richtig aus und ich in berne
tropfen natürlich alles und falls er
dieses rezept nach machen wollt geht
aufs eis - blog.de da stehen noch mal
die zutaten und dann wünsche ich euch
jetzt schon mal ganz viel spaß beim
nachbacken bis zum nächsten mal tschüss